in der weihnachtszeit wird halo herzlich
willkommen so salis welt heute geht es
ein richtig tolles er vor allem für die
weihnachtszeit gerne auch für eure
weihnachtsmenü und zwar habe ich diese
kugel hier gemacht also ich muss zugeben
die sehen auf den ersten blick täuschend
echt aus könne man nicht meinen dass es
ein dessert ist aber diese kugel ist
eine schoko kugel und innen habe ich ein
marzipan muss und es passt geschmacklich
wunderbar zusammen
mir gehts aber heute vielmehr erst
einmal um die optik wie ihr diese kugel
hinbekommt ihnen könnt ihr nämlich
fühlen wie ihr möchtet
ich muss jetzt zuerst einmal mit der
kugel starten und dafür habe ich bereits
400 gramm weiße kuvertüre geschmolzen
da ist ganz wichtig dass die kuvertüre
temperiert wird das heißt zwei drittel
der kuvertüre schmelz sich über einen
warmen wasserbad das wasserbad darf
allerdings nicht mehr kochen von daher
nimmt am besten immer sofort von der
kochstelle herunter und schmilzt die
schokolade dann darin
und sobald die zwei drittel der
schokolade geschmolzen sind kommt das
restliche drittel mit rein und so darf
dann die kuvertüre auf die gewünschte
und perfekte temperatur herunter kühlen
jetzt hat die kuvertüre die perfekte
temperatur alles ist schön geschmolzen
und sie fließt wunderbar und jetzt hatte
ich hier diese hohlkörper und zwar so
dass die kugeln die ihr in jedem
supermarkt oder bastelladen bekommt ich
habe es jetzt bei uns ja beim globus
geholt und die haben einen durchmesser
von fünf zentimetern größere würde ich
jetzt nicht nehmen weil einfach dass der
sehr viel zu groß und viel zu mächtig
wird und das ist jetzt echt cool
die habe ich jetzt schon ausgewaschen
und da fühle ich jetzt die schokolade
rein
und ich habe jetzt hier ein bisschen
mehr als 1 esslöffel schokolade genommen
das darf jetzt nicht zu wenig sein damit
die schoko höhle später nicht zu dünn
wird und bricht jetzt kann ich das hier
verschließen
am besten versetzt wenn man nämlich so
macht kriegt man später ganz schnell
wieder auf also einmal versetzen und am
besten mit klebestreifen fixieren damit
die kugel nicht aufgeht und jetzt schön
hin und her schwenken damit sich die
schokolade gut verteilt und so werde ich
jetzt gleich alle befüllen und sie dann
ins gefrierfach stellen und dann einfach
jede minute einmal so kurz durchrühren
damit die schokolade nicht an einer
stelle zu dick wird
während die schokokugeln im gefrierfach
nur fest werden kann ich die deko weiter
vorbereiten und das ist übrigens auch
ein paar den könnt ihr wirklich auch
schon tage vorher zu bereiten und auch
vorbereiten
die kugeln im gefrierfach lagern und die
deko ist dann auch schon fertig und wenn
ihr dann das weihnachts ist er machen
möchte dann ist es wirklich super
schnell zubereitet habe hier ein
bisschen blüten passte bereits weiß
geknetet und rolle sie auch etwas becker
stärke ganz dünn aus
daraus werde ich jetzt gleich nämlich
die namensschilder machen
beziehungsweise die botschaft
draufschreiben
das sieht ganz kurz hier an der seite
bisschen an trocken da kann ich nämlich
gleich die lebensmittel stift zu nehmen
und dann ein bisschen was drauf
schreiben
jetzt habe ich hier noch ein bisschen
schwarze modell schokolade auf bereits
weiß geknetet und damit werde ich jetzt
hier oben diesen anhänger zu bereiten
einmal die höhe und dann nehme ich für
hier oben einfach ein ausstecher und
damit die schönen hoch werden nehme ich
jetzt hier die ein zentimeter teig
hölzer und kann hier drüber rollen und
dann ist alles gleichmäßig jetzt stehe
ich hier zehn kreise aus zwei sind
einfach zum ersatz damit ich was da
abfalls aus kaputt geht und dafür nehme
ich jetzt einfach eine spritztour
und dann habe ich hier diese kleinen
anhänger
jetzt kann ich die restlichen module
schokolade dünn ausrollen und an diesem
ausstecher hier verwenden und zehn
kleine blumen ausstechen und wer diesen
blumen ausstechen ich hab da kann auch
einen stern form oder auch eine andere
blumen form verwenden
auf die blumen streiche ich jetzt ein
bisschen s-bahn kleber und klebt sie
dann an den anhänger
gibt es nämlich etwas metallic spray das
gibt es in verschiedenen farben und
besprüht ihr anhänger jetzt noch damit
die blüten pasta kann ich jetzt zu
schneiden dafür nehme ich das diese
klett ihr könnt aber auch ein normales
messer mit einem lineal nehmen
so habe ich ein bisserl einfacher denn
ich kann fünf streifen noch einmal zu
schneiden
damit schreibe ich hier einfach meine
frohe botschaft drauf
hier zeige ich die streifen auseinander
und schneide noch hinten einfach so eine
ferne spitze ab und zum aufhängen kommt
noch ein kleines loch an das ende
zum trocknen lege ich sie jetzt leicht
gewellt über diese stifte
jetzt ist es an der zeit die
schokokugeln herauszulösen und von außen
sieht man auch ganz gut dass die sich
zusammen gezogen habt das heißt es war
wirklich lange genug im gefrierfach und
es ist auch super wichtig jetzt kann ich
es ganz vorsichtig herauslösen
jetzt habe ich hier diesen rand und die
nehme ich jetzt einfach mit einem
scharfen messer weg damit die kugel
schön glatt ist es brauche ich natürlich
eine öffnung damit ich das muss gleich
rein füllen kann
ich nehme jetzt eine spritztour dies
eher aus edelstahl und wenn es jetzt ein
bisschen wahr machen und kann dann ein
loch einbringen und die luft kühle mache
ich jetzt auch immer wieder sauber
damit die schokolade daran nicht
verbrennt jetzt bekommt die kugel farbe
jetzt zieh dich am besten handschuhe an
und legt auch in der küche alle sind
papier aus oder ihr arbeitet einfach
gleich am waschbecken hinten so würde
ich es normalerweise auch machen ohne
kamera
ich hatte die kugel nochmal etwa 15
minuten im kühlschrank jetzt sind sie
schön fest und ich habe mich jetzt
einfach auf so einen cake pops tick
drauf ihr könnt aber zum beispiel auch
ein hölzchen nehmen und jetzt einfach
die dose gut wieder durch schütteln und
dann die kugel damit bestreuen und
anschließend kann ich sie dann hier auf
seine styropor teil einfach aufspielten
wenn ihr etwas weniger farbe verbrauchen
wollt dann sprüht die farbe einfach in
eurer hand ich habe hier noch die reste
von gerade eben
und dann könnt ihr die kugel in der hand
ganz vorsichtig hin und her rollen und
dann ist die kugel wunderbar bedeckt und
sie trocknet auch viel schneller jetzt
in die deko kugeln vorbereitet und ich
kann mich um das muss kümmern
ich werde es jetzt mit einem marzipan
muss befüllen ihr könnt aber auch gerne
ein schoko mousse oder sogar ein mousse
au chocolat zaubern und das hineinfühlen
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal wasser
aufkochen lassen kann das ganz kurz
ausmachen und zeigt euch hier nochmal
die zutaten für das klauen kompott
brauche ich ein glas pflaumen ich habe
hier bereits das wasser abgelassen und
aufgefangen
30 gramm stärke den saft einer zitrone
und eine zimtstange und für das moos
brauche ich 100 gramm marzipanrohmasse
das ist jetzt lübecker 2 weiß zehn gramm
gaga 100 milliliter wasser 150 gramm
sahne und einen esslöffel moden zuerst
kümmere ich mich jetzt um das frauen
kompott damit es abkühlen kann
dafür gebe ich jetzt den saft in einen
topf und das ist der saft von den
eingelegten pflaumen und da gebe ich
jetzt noch weil er ja leicht süßlich ist
zitronensaft dazu von der ganzen zitrone
da könnt ihr den säuregrad einfach
selber bestimmen ich gebe es einen
kompletten saft mit rein
ihr könnt aber auch gerne nur die hälfte
nehmen
hier höre ich jetzt noch die stärke 1
und ich verzichte hier auch auf zucker
weil die flammen schon leicht süßlich
sind und weil das muss natürlich süß
sein soll und das kompott ein bisschen
säuerlicher jetzt schön glatt rühren
jetzt kommt hier noch gezielt stange mit
rein und ich kann das ganze jetzt auch
schon mal aufkommen lassen und in der
zwischenzeit die flammen fein würfeln
wenn ihr merkt dass hier noch etwas
flüssigkeit benötigt dann können nur
noch ein bisschen wasser oder zum
beispiel zu folgen
jetzt kommen hier die pflaumen stücke
mit rein und werden dann eingerührt und
dann kann ich das kompott zum abkühlen
zur seite stellen
bei uns ist heute draußen kalt das heißt
ich denke ab und kann dann auf die
terrasse stellen
jetzt nämlich zuerst die
marzipanrohmasse und reife sie ganz fein
in eine metallschüssel hier kommt jetzt
das eiweiß mit dazu die eiweiß marzipan
masse wird jetzt über dem heißen
wasserbad für etwa fünf minuten verrührt
so wird das eiweiß pasteurisiert und
kommt eben über die 60 grad und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich dann auch schon
mal wasser mit dem agatha aufkochen und
es zwei minuten sprudelnd kochen lassen
die marzipan massa habe ich jetzt nach
dem erwärmen hier kalt gerührt und des
agatha ist jetzt auch gut eingekauft
also zwei minuten sprudelnd und jetzt
kann ich das hier langsam einrühren
und die zwischenzeit habe ich auch
genutzt um die sahne steif schlagen und
die kann ich jetzt hier noch unterheben
und wer lust hat gibt an der stelle
einfach noch ein bisschen monat
und jetzt fühle ich dass muss in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer großen machtfülle
jetzt müsst ihr hier den rest gut
vorbereitet haben denn das muss wirklich
relativ schnell fest ich nehme sie ein
bisschen flüssige schokolade und gibt so
ein tröpfchen auf eine back folie oder
ein backpapier und zwar bewegt dieses
tröpfchen schokolade dass ich gleich die
kugel dran kleben kann ohne dass sie
eben auch wegrutscht das könnte aber
auch gerne schon im vorfeld vorbereiten
kurz im kühlschrank stellen so dass es
wirklich schön fest ist
das ankleben der kugel funktioniert
übrigens am besten wenn ihr unter der
toten platte also unter dem torten
retter eingesperrt habt so wird nämlich
die schokolade schön fest und klebt
einfach bombenfest an
jetzt werde ich die kugel mit dem
pflaumenmus füllen das habe ich einfach
vorher kurz passiert bzw
mit dem stabmixer einfach gut
zerkleinert und es kommt jetzt hier
unten rein
und jetzt will ich die kugel komplett
mit dem marzipan muss die kugeln
verschließe ich jetzt mit einem topf von
weißer schokolade
klebe dann die ausgesprochene blume
drauf und klebt dann noch den anhänger
dran
so sieht das dessert dann fertig aus ich
finde es wirklich wunder um das schön am
set habe ich natürlich jetzt versucht
das ganze so schön wie möglich
aufzubrechen
hast du erst ein messer warm gemacht und
dann die kugel ein bisschen aufgebrochen
aber ihr könnt es auch wirklich mit
einem ganz normalen messer und einem
dessert löffel aufbrechen
und dann sieht das ganze innen so aus
wirklich super lecker hier kann ich ja
mal zeigen
guck mal stoff nicht schön ihnen diese
pflaumen dieses pflaumenmus obendrüber
die marzipan muss mit den mond stückchen
recht findet sie zur lecker aus sehr
lecker murat wird auf jeden fall
begeistert sein
ich nehme dieses es jetzt einfach mit zu
einem geburtstag ich hoffe dass er sie
ausprobieren werde und nach machen werde
ich hoffe auch dass ich kein mond
zwischen in szenen ab falls doch dann
ist auch egal denn das sehe ich dann
erst im anschluss falls er das rezept
nach machen wollen dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei aufs ellis - blog.de
ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei wünsche
euch einen guten appetit und mir
natürlich auch bis zum nächsten mal